I do want to talk about big things
important things going on with the show
and it sort of does relate to membership
so let me just go into that now get it
out of the way then we'll move on to
hatred mail and having a grand old time
here at David Pakman show studios so
let's just catch you up on what's going
on I've not been talking about this a
lot but I do need to talk to you today
really about the plan that we have and I
hope you'll be a part of to keep the
david pakman show afloat amidst a total
and utter implosion so to give you the
background it's been a really difficult
five plus months for the David Pakman
show
ad pocalypse YouTube ad pocalypse
started on March 31st of 2017 and on
that day effectively overnight we lost
99% of our YouTube revenue now you might
listen to the podcast you might watch on
TV or radio and you might say I don't
care about YouTube YouTube doesn't make
a difference and that's fine but what
you should know is that YouTube as a
revenue generating source was a big part
of what we were doing up nearly half of
our revenue used to come from YouTube
and it subsidized all other aspects of
the show the total implosion that took
place was sort of precipitated by some
controversial articles written by The
Wall Street Journal and others which
alleged that YouTube's ad filtering
system couldn't prevent ads from big
companies like coca-cola and others from
being placed in front of racist and
hateful videos now many of you who watch
on YouTube know this wasn't actually a
problem in fact if anything the system
was too strict rather than too relaxed
if we even talked about the
israeli-palestinian conflict those
videos would not make money on YouTube
so really this was a solution through a
problem that didn't exist this problem
sort of evident flowed in April and May
looked like maybe revenue was starting
to come back but ultimately revenue from
YouTube is down about 85 to 88 percent
okay we have our revenue chart to put up
on the screen and we started the year
very strong point to is YouTube ad
pocalypse 3 is when it looked like
things were improving and 4 is
ultimately where we are now and I keep
waiting around for things to improve
and so I can say hey you know what
everything's fine financially we don't
have to worry about it it's just not
going to happen and in fact if you now
google on Google News YouTube D
monetization you will find endless hours
of reading about this issue and the
revenue is not coming back and there's
been some horrible public incidents that
are only making this worse recently one
of the major youtubers who goes by the
name PewDiePie said the n-word in one of
his videos again terrible publicity for
the ad safe nature of YouTube videos
even though of course it has nothing to
do with anything that we're doing on the
David Pakman show we are FCC safe
because we are on broadcast radio and
television this is terrible publicity
and we are now effectively writing off
YouTube revenue as a source of revenue
for the show we just can't count on it
providing operating funds for the show
we've had the benefit of a couple major
advertisers getting in touch with the
program offering a lot of money but the
truth is they're not ideologically
aligned with us they're not oil
companies but they're not great fits
either and so that really is you know
the companies that have a lot of money
to pour in typically they don't want to
deal with shows as small as ours we're
not big enough for big advertisers to
work with us directly and the couple
that have approached us so far are just
not good fits and I wouldn't feel good
about having those advertisers on the
show so there's a couple of ways the
show could go one is we basically say
listen this is it this is the show we
have to scale back we can replace lost
revenue with ads if there's a fit that
is OK and we sort of have to postpone
the ideas for future growth of the show
the other possibility which is what I
want to do and I hope it's what you want
to do if you value the program is we say
hey we're gonna replace the lost revenue
we're gonna replace the lost revenue in
a few different ways and we're gonna get
beyond the lost revenue and then we're
actually going to start doing not only
the new stuff we've had planned for you
for the last year or so but all sorts of
other new content and we will have
actually if we're able to do that total
independence I don't want to be doing
these segments and pledges and
fundraising and membership drives any
more than you probably
want me to but I have to do it I have to
do it so that we can keep doing five
shows a week and again when you look at
the revenue curve that I put up on the
screen for you the proof is in the
pudding so what am I asking for I'm
really not asking for much remember when
we were on vacation for a couple of
weeks our summer vacation and there was
no new content a lot of people wrote in
saying hey you know I signed up for
membership during your vacation because
now I know what you mean by if all of a
sudden the david pakman show was gone I
had a sixty or seventy five eighty
minute hole in my day that I was used to
spending with you hearing about the news
and it was all of a sudden empty and a
lot of people realized hey a couple
bucks a month is very fair for the
programming that you provide and that's
all we're talking about right we really
only need a few bucks a month from 3% of
our audience
okay these are some surprising numbers
to a lot of people in our audience we
estimate that around 1% of our audience
contributes financially to the program
okay and that's great the show should be
free but if you can't afford just a few
dollars that's how we're funded and if
we could go from one percent of our
audience funding us to three percent of
our audience funding us even at a dollar
or two a day we can forget about the
fundraising and the pledge drives and we
can just move on to talking about and
planning for and producing all the great
content that I want to produce now if
you want to read more about how this has
affected us there's a couple of really
good articles that have been written one
is in The New York Times The New York
Times and Amanda Hess wrote an article
about how the David Pakman show is
getting crushed on YouTube Wired
magazine and davey alba wrote a great
article about how the david pakman show
is getting crushed those articles are
available on the press page at david
pakman.com we are starting new
initiatives for our subscribers we are
restarting supporter only live streams
where everybody gets to hang out invite
only ask questions if you sign up for
membership or patreon you will get
invited to those support or only live
streams
two ways to support us and really please
consider whether you think this is worth
a couple of bucks a month I believe that
it is number one is membership okay you
go to david pakman.com slash membership
you pick your membership and you click
on the red signup button and on the
second page of the signup process if you
want a 40% off coupon code you can use
coupon code I've voted 17 if you're not
yet ready to commit to membership go to
david pakman.com slash dollar you can
get $1 trial membership for a week if
you like it stick with it almost
everybody who has done the trial
membership continues to be a member
because they realize this is really
really great stuff okay membership it's
huge supporter livestreams the entire
thing is happening patreon okay
previously when you went to patreon.com
slash david pakman show and donated a
dollar or two or five or whatever you
receive no benefits we have changed that
you can now get the behind the scenes
videos and Members Only updates at the
$2 level on patreon we can keep patreon
up at the $5 level you can get access to
the bonus show previously only available
to members at the $10 level on patreon
you can get access to the full show and
bonus shows previously only accessible
to members and as you'll see on the left
side if you're watching with us here we
are at 1902 patrons which is just short
of our goal of 2,000 we are 98 new
patrons away from 2000 what happens at
2000 I do an entire show from the
broadcast studio with my hair untamed
which a lot of people have been asking
for for a while what is David's hair
like when there's no product in his hair
you will find out for an entire live
show when we get to 2,000 patrons when
we get to 3,000 patrons we are going to
be creating exclusive patreon only
content including regular patreon patron
thank-you videos as well as additional
news and politics stories just for our
patrons that's patreon.com slash david
pakman show donate $1 donate $2 donate 5
or 10 okay this really is going to make
or break the show it's
/ with YouTube I wish it were different
I wish we hadn't lost 85 to 88 percent
of what made up half of our total
revenue it's the reality I can't change
it but what I can do is be upfront with
you about what's going on and explain to
you that this revenue has to be replaced
and I'm asking for your help to do it